hey guys
my name is aman hamilton and you may
know me from my streams over at the
trash bra channel
i've also represented canada at the
olympiad twice
and also coached the canadian women's
team at that exact same tournament
i'm also relatively famous for growing a
crazy long beard and saying that i'm
never going to shave it off until i
became a grandmaster
which thankfully i did at the end of
2017.
i wanted to take you guys on a trip down
memory lane
looking at a game of mine that i played
in the canadian open one of the
strongest tournaments that canada has
this was in 2010 july i was
2131 fide at the time and
i was playing against grandmaster josh
friedel
who was 25-27 v-day at the time
we reached this position on the board
and this
was the move that i played
queen h7 check kind of a startling move
uh certainly shocked my opponent
whose last move obviously allowed this
to happen and he had no idea it was
coming
but in order to properly understand why
this move was so special
i want to first take you guys back and
see how this game came to be
so i'm taking you back to move seven and
we're going to very quickly go through
this game
um as a 2100 playing grandmaster i was
outmatched
and right out of the opening you can see
that
my opponent is playing very aggressively
and i did not know how to handle it
so my opponent builds up an overwhelming
position
much uh as you would expect the grand
master to do against
his 2100 rated opponent and pretty
quickly here
after the move f3 bishop d7 you can see
that with bishop a4 coming
and knight b3 check and the skewer here
i was in big big trouble
i played the move b3 and even though it
might look like
i'm taking his knight look at my
development it's terrible
i'm not even following habits here
and we can see the position builds up
to what looks to be an insurmountable um
attack i mean i i don't know how i'm
supposed to deal with this
and i play the move h4 desperation pure
desperation guys
and here with the movie h takes g5
i have a very devious idea which you
guys already know
which is queen h7 and my opponent didn't
see it coming
so he played the new queen d5 i don't
know what the evaluation here is
probably like minus 13 minus 15
something crazy crazy high
the game's completely over there are a
lot of moves here that win for black
knight c1 being one of them
and there are many many more obviously
queen takes pawn is another one just
dealing with my threats on the king side
but my opponent maybe took his foot off
the gas a little bit
thought the game was already in the bag
brings the queen to the center attacks
the bishop and aims at my king
totally forgetting that i'm not
threatening
rook takes h6 and then checkmate i'm
actually threatening
one of my uh proudest moves and the
first time i was able to beat a grand
master was in this game right here
queen h7 check uh that's check to the
king it has to be taken
it is a free queen but what i'm able to
do as a follow-up
is rook takes h6 check and with the
bishop and rook supporting the h8 square
i'm able to deliver a forced checkmate
on black's king and if you look at the
final position i i'm only using two of
my pieces
i've got three guys doing absolutely
nothing back here i sacked my queen from
c2 and my king
is getting checkmated 10 different ways
so this was the
as i said first time i had ever beaten a
grand master i was only 2100
at the time it was a very special moment
for my chess career because
i was able to uncork a queen sacrifice
in front of a lot of people and
you know the the emotions were running i
was practically shaking as i was
uh getting the queen over to age seven i
remember the arbiters even asked me
after the game
if i recorded the result incorrectly
because they saw the game was over
after everybody was looking at my king
assuming i got checkmated so
pretty uh pretty big moment for me and
uh hope you guys enjoyed
what was one of the best chess moves of
my career
[Music]
you